on les attendait depuis plusieurs
semaines ils sont maintenant disponibles
les premiers tests de dépistage des
anticorps contre la coved 19 approuvé
par santé canada déteste qu'on appelle
sérologique avec une simple prise de
sang elles permettent de vérifier si
vous avez développer les anticorps
contre la coved 19 une protection
immunitaire qu'on acquiert après avoir
été infectés par le virus qu'on a eu des
symptômes ou pas le réseau de cliniques
médicales brisville le ferai dès ce
matin les clients étaient là d'abord
pour se rassurer
j'ai l'impression que peut-être moi et
m'ont fait son rôle ait eu en étant avec
le public puis avec les employés tout
pour voir un peu quelques années mais on
va garder nos vies notre sécurité à 200
dollars le test et cinq jours pour
obtenir les résultats des centaines de
personnes étaient déjà sur les listes
d'attentes
les corps policiers par exemple veulent
savoir les médecins des infirmiers les
premiers mais aussi des personnes qui
ont un certain arrangement 60 ans et
plus il veut recommencer à travailler où
ils veulent recommencer avoir des
contacts sociaux un peu plus régulier le
texte approuvé par santé canada a
démontré une très bonne fiabilité
il détecte plus de 97% des cas de co
vite positif et presque tous les cas
négatifs mais ce test aussi utile soit
il a ses limites
rappel la santé publique du canada et
minalogic oft dans la même foulée santé
canada annoncé que d'ici deux ans elle
réelle serait un million de tests
aléatoires sur la population canadienne
afin d'évaluer la progression de la
maladie au pays et déterminer si on
s'approche de ce qu'on appelle
l'immunité collective
c'est une étape importante pour mieux
comprendre les mécanismes d'immunisation
contre le virus et la façon dont il se
propage ça va nous aider à assurer la
santé et la sécurité des canadiens
aux etats-unis une dizaine de tests
sérologiques ont déjà été approuvées
dont certains sont encore plus
performant que
unique tests disponibles pour l'instant
au pays les normands grondin radio
canada montréal